BABATUNDE OGUNLADE:
Hello, everyone.
Today we'll be working
through Goodie Bag
3, which is on ionic solids.
In order to work
through this Goodie Bag,
you'll need a conductivity
meter, some small measuring
cups, some medium sized cups, a
small scale, a writing utensil,
some nitrile gloves,
some stirrers,
and four unique solids.
Today, I'll be using sodium
chloride, magnesium sulfate,
magnesium oxide, and sucrose.
Our main objective today is to
use solubility and conductivity
measurements to determine
if a given solid is
an ionic or covalent compound.
And as we do this, I'd like you
to think about two questions.
First, how do solids
dissolve in water?
And second, what factors
may influence how conductive
a given solid is in water?
So first we're going to look
at the solubility of our solids
in water.
And to do this, we're going to
dissolve 1 gram of each solid
in 30 milliliters of water.
I've already weighed
out my solids here.
And I've also already
weighed out my water.
Notice how I'm wearing a
pair of nitrile gloves.
The compounds that
I'm working with today
aren't that dangerous, but
just as general safety,
it's good to wear gloves
when handling compounds.
So I'm going to pour each
solute into each respective cup
of water and stir and mix for
about a minute to two minutes
and see if the
compound dissolves.
So after one to two minutes
of stirring and dissolving,
you can see that our magnesium
oxide right here has not
dissolved in our water.
You can see a very clear
boundary between the solute,
which has settled at
the bottom of the cup,
and the water, which is on top.
If you compare that to
our sodium chloride,
though, if you look
very carefully,
you can see that our
solute has dissolved
very well in our water.
So the next thing
we'll be doing is
measuring the conductivity
of our compounds
when dissolved in water.
And to do that,
we're going to be
using a handy dandy conductivity
meter that I have right here.
So I have some cups
of water prepared here
to be used as both a
baseline correction
when we're measuring our
conductivity of our compounds
and as a water bath to clean our
probe in between measurements.
OK, so first I'm going to turn
on my conductivity measure.
And I'm going to make
sure that my units are
set to microsiemens
per centimeter,
or some equivalent unit.
And first I'm going to measure
a baseline of just regular water
here.
I have tap water here.
And so when I do
that, I see that I'm
measuring around 900
microsiemens per centimeter.
So that is the connectivity
of my water as is.
And I'm going to use
that as a baseline
when I'm measuring
the connectivity
of my other compounds.
So since this is water,
it's already clean,
and now I'm going to measure
my sodium chloride, which
is right here.
And so right now I'm reading
around 4,700 microsiemens
per centimeter for
my sodium chloride.
I'm going to take note of that.
And eventually, when
I'm collecting my data,
I'm going to subtract my water
baseline from this value here.
Make sure in between
each measurement
that you dip the probe in
the water bath to clean it,
and you can continue on with
the rest of your measurements.
So the last experiment
we're going to do today
is to measure the
solubility of our compounds
in water, except with 2
grams instead of 1 gram.
So I've measured out an
additional 1 gram of each solid
here, and I'm just
going to pour each one
into each respective
cup, mix and stir.
And after one to
two minutes, I'm
going to see if each
compound is dissolved.
So again, we have
our magnesium oxide
after round two of solubility.
Again, we can see that
our solute has not
dissolved in water.
There's a very clear boundary
between the water on top
and the solute on the bottom.
So in this case, round
one solubility and round
two solubility look
identical, but it may not
be the case for our
other three solutes.
All right, so now that we've
finished our last solubility
test, let's put all our data--
our first solubility test,
our connectivity test,
and our second solubility test--
on the board.
So here we have a chart of all
the data from our experiments.
I have the compounds that we
use going down right here.
And I have solubility here
at 1 gram and 2 grams,
and conductivity after
water subtraction here.
So before going into
this data, first thing
I would like us to notice
is that for sodium chloride
and for magnesium sulfate,
these conductivity values
are much lower than I expected.
This should be close to
the 10,000 microsiemens,
and this should be closer
to 8,000 microsiemens
per centimeter, but
the fact that we're
able to measure conductivity
for these respective compounds
gives us insight into what
type of compounds they are.
So first, if we look
at sodium chloride,
we could see that at
both 1 gram and 2 grams,
our sodium chloride was
able to dissolve in water.
And we were able to measure
conductivity readings for this.
This means our
sodium chloride was
able to dissociate into ions
when dissolved in water.
And this is an
extra check for us
to determine that sodium
chloride is indeed
an ionic compound.
Next we can look
at magnesium oxide.
And we see that for magnesium
oxide, at 1 gram and 2 grams,
we weren't able to dissolve
the magnesium oxide in water.
And not only that,
because of that,
we weren't able to
measure any conductivity.
But we know that magnesium
oxide is an ionic compound
just from our
understanding of bonding.
So we had to think more closely
about why this is the case.
So magnesium oxide
and sodium chloride
are both ionic compounds,
but magnesium oxide
has a much higher lattice
energy than sodium chloride.
This means that when magnesium
oxide is placed in water,
it's more energetically
favorable for it
to stay as a solid than it
is to dissociate into ions
of magnesium and oxygen.
So magnesium oxide is still
an ionic compound, but
it's lattice energy
is high enough such that it does
not dissolve and does not give
us conductivity measurements.
So it's still ionic.
Now we can look at
magnesium sulfate.
And we see that for 1 gram,
we do get some solubility.
And at 2 grams, we
get no solubility.
It was not able to dissolve.
And we're able to measure
some conductivity.
This means that magnesium
sulfate dissociated
into respective ions and
we're able to measure
some conductivity
while in water.
But magnesium sulfate
has a limited solubility
in water, which
is why at 2 grams
it wasn't able to
dissolve completely.
So magnesium sulfate is
still an ionic compound.
Finally, if we
look at sucrose, we
see that we were able
to get 1 gram of sucrose
to dissolve in water,
and 2 grams of sucrose
was able to dissolve in water.
But we were not able to
get any conductivity.
This means that sucrose
dissolved in water,
but did not dissociate
into respective ions.
So if you think about
the structure of sucrose,
sucrose has a bunch of polar
groups on it, which make
it able to dissolve in water.
But sucrose does not
dissociate into ions,
which is why we were not able
to measure any conductivity.
So sucrose is a
covalent compound.
So by using our knowledge of
bonding and our solubility
and conductivity data,
we're able to affirm
the identity of our compounds.
That is, whether or not
they're ionic or covalent.
So today we looked
at how the type
and strength of
bonding of a solid
influences its properties.
Specifically, we looked at
how these aspects of bonding
influence these solubility
and conductivity
of these solids in water.